congratulations on the nomination it's
awesome to be back here got to come with
mom so you must be proud I don't get the
focus back there oh you look like your
mama
thank you I think that's a compliment my
mom's beautiful it's a beautiful one -
you made a very handsome son your second
year in a row to be nominated this is
really sweet
yeah like just I'm agent Bryan is like
said you feel more relaxed or two fuel
and this feels as crazy I'm so thrilled
to be here I'm seeing so many people
that are awesome artists and actors
musicians musicians and actresses so
this is cool I feel a little I feel a
little no I mean no it's pretty nervous
yeah it's pretty nervous here oh no no
no you've got
Saoirse and laura dern or both here
tonight you know yeah and yeah um yeah
no awesome super super proud and we all
we have we had a group text on that
movie so good to see them again yeah
it's not alone night you had one no it's
not life and well math because that
movie is not in production anymore but
it'll come out and hopefully sometime
next year
after you're right but this thing the
sad thing happens at the end of movies
where like things kind of it's weird
every I don't know every project I do I
always think I'm gonna keep in touch
with everyone forever thinks I'm a
shallow from like a stars boy I fell I
wish I wish I could I could butcher it I
could no forgive me give me a song give
me other song really as anybody else
done it
what's the exact melody in the shallow
shallow in the shallow shallow Zephyr he
comes about as spoken song yeah as long
as it gets
LGBTQ Center in New York thank you
[Music]
[Applause]
[Music]